[Music]
arrows do bounce you can skip arrows off
the ground I've seen people skip arrows
along water hello uh I'm Jim Kent known
to The Wider world as Grizzly Jim uh I'm
a traditional Archer YouTube Creator I'm
lucky enough to have traveled all over
the world uh sharing my passion for
traditional archery today I'm back to
look at some archery clips from film and
TV to judge how real they
are my boy he's at full draw there he's
got a pretty pretty solid anchor can see
him massively Flinch as he as he shoots
once you've been shooting for a while
you you get over that you you don't have
that Flinch you don't anticipate the
shot so much but when you're fairly new
to archery that's something that's
that's pretty
typical but he's given the feather a
lick I don't know why you do it why I
mean why would you lick it I mean that's
been in the dirt
[Music]
an arrow will spin as it flies through
the air especially with a with a feather
feathers come in two flavors you've got
left wing or right wing one will make it
spin one way the other will make it spin
the other but it doesn't fly straight
arrows when they fly through the air
they oscillate like crazy cuz you got
all this energy uh coming from the back
uh and pushing is usually fairly weighty
up front it takes a couple of seconds
for the back to catch up with the front
so you end up with this hugely
oscillating Arrow flying through the
air obviously the the more tension in
the Rope the easier it would be to cut
there wasn't much weight there it would
be very difficult to cut but if it's
under a lot of tension that would cut
through quite
nicely I don't know to this day why he
rips a feather off because they compress
to almost nothing but you can shoot two
arrows off a bow you can do that it's
not an efficient way of doing things the
the bow doesn't know that there's two
arrows on the bow the bow just thinks
there's one very heavy arrow and
obviously the heavier the arrow the more
energy is used up trying to propel that
Arrow I think I'm going to have to go
eight just because of the that the the
feather
thing if I use a quiver I tend to use a
b quiver it gives you a nice low profile
Quivers you tend to either wear on your
hip or your or your side or your back uh
when you're in the woods you you tend
want to keep a sort of Fairly slim
profile so back quiver is quite
useful arrows do make a noise when you
shoot them but they don't quite make a
noise like you expect them to unless you
use something called a flu flu which is
an arrow with really big feathers on the
end the noise that they make is so
satisfying now he's he's got this weird
grip on the string he's got the arrow on
the on the left side of the bow I think
and he's holding the string like that
which is isn't what you do if you really
wanted to hold the string upside down
you'd need the you'd need the arrow on
the right side of the bow I imagine
that's that's more of an aesthetic thing
than than
anything you can hear as as he draws up
you can hear the bow creaking now this
is a Trope and that's when the bow comes
up to full draw you hear it creak
bows don't Creak if your Bow's creaking
when you come up to full draw it's
probably going to explode on you but the
Archer is a little bit all over the shop
I'm going to go
six yeah I'm going to get some hate in
the comments for that one but I love
Lord of the Rings so don't don't come
for
[Music]
me I've tried this and what what
actually happens is when you wrap
something around an arrow uh and shoot
it the arrow goes but that tends to stay
so you end up with with a a bit of linen
on fire by your fingers which which
isn't a great idea I'm sure there was
other ways of doing it but it was
actually a small cage on the end of uh
end of the arrow that had had something
flammable in the cage so when you when
you shot the arrow the force the arrow
going forward didn't force it down the
arrow
shaft it's all about uh quantity over
quality so you'd send a lot lot of
arrows Skyward up and over to try and
sort of rain down hell on on on the
opposing side um the very famous uh
English uh uh battle um the Battle of
Anin cor where you know the the English
famously won the day because of their
archers doing exactly
that I kind of like the way the arrows
are bouncing off the shields that's
quite that's quite
realistic
I would have definitely uh employed that
tactic if I was a Troy got a bracer on
protect his arm from the uh from the
string so what what happens is when you
when you draw uh a bow back and let it
go the string in an ideal world would
come nice and straight past your arm but
it doesn't because it comes off the
fingers if you see a string in slow
motion it actually comes comes towards
the bow like this so a lot of time you
you tend to sort of bash your arm with
the string and that sort of bracer there
would would potentially stop that give
that one a
seven she's got an anchor Point sort of
under her chin she's looking very very
straight very good sort of target
archery style and there's nothing wrong
with target archery style but it is very
good for shooting set distances she's
going to be sort of competing in the
Hunger Game so she's going to be in sort
of more combat sort of situations so
that isn't really the right sort of
archery for that sort of
scenario she's going very quickly and
you see it a lot in films where people
are shooting very quickly archery for me
anyway is always a little bit more
measured a little bit more take your
time a little bit like get that perfect
shot off um because it takes a long time
to kind of load your bow up again and
shoot again in the Middle East they do
they do sort of sort of archery where
he's very quickly loading the bow
shooting very rapidly and it's it's an
amazing skill I imagine the bow is is a
very low poundage because the pound is
required to actually do any damage
you're going to need sort of a fair bit
of poundage there and it takes time to
pull it back so she's she's not really
shooting with the the the greatest
amount of kind of back tension and
stuffs at that short distance that would
that would work it's not the prettiest
but you know in that sort of situation
you're not trying to be elegant you're
not trying to be pretty you're trying to
save your life visually very impressive
but you wouldn't use that technique in a
competition we'll give that one an eight
some of the movements are a little bit
out there it's not necessarily right but
it's quite
realistic 175 yards a one he's talking
about a very long way to be very
accurate with a long B now I'm sure
people were pretty accurate back then
but the equipment was very basic the the
arrows were very basic archery is all
about consistency and in in this these
sort of times you wouldn't have had the
the technology to make an arrow exactly
the same as another arrow you couldn't
weigh them exactly the same they can't
see
us maybe they thought that was
like they were typically sort of about
as tall as you so you know 6ot plus for
really smacking an arrow in a longbow
really does Hammer Hammer the uh the
arrows home very big draw Force curve
lot of energy uh if you look at sort of
more war war bows which is a a very high
poundage English long bow sort of 80 lb
plus the bow I shoot is is about 45 to
50b in draw weight which is quite
substantial I shot a 120 PB bow once and
it down near folded me in half
he's put his hand in his in his his
pouch and he's he's he's putting a
powder on his fingers possibly a resin
or something I'm guessing it's to help
him get a Smooth release on the
string there's not a lot wrong with that
uh it looks pretty pretty solid his head
barely moves a lot of people when
they're first getting into archery will
be so focused on where the arrows go and
they'll shoot and they'll move their
head to try and look look past the bow
and see where it is he makes the shot
his head doesn't move and I like that
that's that's a really good that's a
really good
technique you missed him
anyway I didn't miss anyone if you can
see through it you can shoot through it
um you don't need a huge amount of space
obviously the smaller the space uh the
more chance you've got of something
going wrong the arrows don't fly
straight so you've got to if you're
shooting through something too small as
the arrow flies through it could clip
the back of in hunting situations arrows
quite often pass through uh an animal
you call it pass through but at that
sort of distance the arrow is going to
lose a lot of energy because what what
feathers do feathers stabilize an arrow
fantastically but they also act as a
parachute so they're going to slow the
arrow down and there were some quite big
feathers on that Arrow bigger the
feathers the more stable but the slower
it's going to go so you know 175 yards
the arrow is going to slow down a bit I
don't know if you get a pass through at
that sort of um that sort of distance so
we'll go seven sorry King
Arthur these guys have shot three arrows
into a cement wall if you shoot an arrow
into something hard it it bounces out
especially if it's Stone any Archer that
that's been shooting for a while and has
taken a bad Miss and has hit a stone or
or missed a Target and hit a wall it it
absolutely pancakes the arrow I can't
actually see the the types of points
they're using on these arrows but if
they're trying to kill people which it
looks like they are in a John Wick movie
they'd be using something called a a
Broadhead but a broad-headed arrow is is
an arrow tip that's designed to cause as
much damage as possible it's usually a
two-bladed three bladed um sharp point
on the end of an
arrow they're doing some very close
range combat there is sort of some
evidence of of of of kind of the more
martial side of archery generally close
range archery is is I don't know it's
not really a thing archeries a long
range mid to long range uh discipline it
takes seconds to to to to to load the
bow to draw the bow to shoot the bow a
guy with a sword could do the job a lot
quicker they're definitely the more sort
of Eastern style bow which is really a
precursor to the modern day recurve bow
she is using it as a club which you
could do but they're generally fairly
light these sorts of bows and she's
kicking the out of guys with armor uh
with with a bow but I I don't know how
effective that would
be you know to to to guys in armor
they're not very heavy pieces of
equipment they're they're made of mostly
sort of a a wood or a wood substitute we
go seven just cuz it it's such a good
scene it's it's really Dynamic it shows
different styles of
archery that would be very heavy and
that would create a lot of weight in the
arrow so the
arrow would probably just flop in front
of her and also she's got to shoot it
over her hand but the thing I really
like about that little section there is
the way the bow moves now if you if you
do happen to to film a bow in slow
motion they they are like a a wet noodle
they are wobbling all over the place
it's it's fascinating to see when you
see something like that in slow motion
and they've got the movement of the bow
completely right that is exactly what a
bow would
do there are people out there that uh
have claimed to catch arrows when I have
seen it done it's kind of more stunts
where the arrow isn't traveling
particularly hard is isn't traveling
particularly fast uh and you sort of
grab it out of the air I've I've seen it
done like that but in a true situation
with a with a with a true bow at a at a
realistic poundage I think you'd
struggle unless it was at a very long
distance and you could you could sort of
track it and whatnot I mean don't do it
because it's you're essentially shooting
an arrow at someone which is which is
stupid so don't ever do that I mean
there was dealing with some kind kind of
fantasy kind of elements there but we'll
give that one an eight I
think
I love this film this is a such a good
archery movie this guy here at full draw
now the bow he's using is a nice little
short uh style hunting bow he's got
really really nice form there he's
wearing finger protection and that's the
first time we've we've seen so when I
actually wear proper finger protection
in any of these scenes and if you shoot
a bow without any sort of finger
protection be that a glove be that tab
it's over time it's going to hurt and
over time it's going to cause serious
damage to your fingers first with
blisters then Nerf
damage release some people really do
prefer to to close one eye and use their
dominant eye to look at the uh look at
the Target they're probably using some
sort of system where they're using their
their eye and the point of the arrow and
sort of working out the distance and
where they need to put that that arrow
on the target to to make the shot I
don't do that I keep both eyes open um
we see in 3d so I like to see what it is
I'm shooting at in 3D I get a bit more
of a a better perspective for where it
is um how how far away it is it's really
good for for distance
judging now this is why I like this
scene so much he's going through
something now called Target panic and
that is a a mental issue I mean it's a
very extreme uh version of of Target
panic but uh he's going through
something and that's you get it with
with with hunting quite a lot you get it
with sort of uh competitions you just
get into your own head and it's very
difficult to to get a shot off and it's
so good to see uh a representation of
someone really struggling with with the
shot and I've I've struggled with Target
panic in films you see everyone shooting
going crazy doing everything perfectly
every time but archery isn't perfect
every
time
what they're doing is uh they're bow
fishing he's got a bow quiver uh
attached to the side of it and he's got
a fishing reel you can tell he's been
coached by someone that knows what
they're doing bow fishing is an
incredibly tough skill and I've got
nothing but respect for anyone that can
bow fish cuz it's not just a case of
seeing the fish because of the
refraction of the water you've actually
got to put it in a different place to
where the fish is it's a it's a whole
skill that I've got nothing but but
respect for machines are going to fail
and the system's going to fail he's got
some very bright um feathers uh on on
his Arrow now they're they're What's
called the the two shapes you tend to
get you get a shield shape and a
parabolic shape they're a parabolic
feather so they're round at the back
very bright colors um Hunters tend to
use quite bright colors on their arrows
uh sort of the oranges the pinks uh the
whites they show up in a a nature
environment quite well uh they help you
track the animal if if you know you
you're looking for the arrow they help
you find lost arrows I think it's a very
realistic representation so I am going
to give Deliverance a
nine bows don't do that uh B bows are
under a lot of tension I I can't think
of a a plausible way that would ever
work you you'd have you'd have to string
the bow you'd have have to put tension
into the bow that's not how bows work it
looks very cool it's very visually
stunning to shoot something far away you
have to shoot above it to shoot the
closer something gets to your sort of
your level the the kind of lower you
have to
get same with if you were sort of clay
pigeon shooting you kind of get a lead
on the Arrow You So you you're you're
not shooting where the thing is that
you're shooting at is you're shooting at
where it's going to be an arrow does
travel
it travels fast but not as fast as a
bullet tracking it requires a sort of
more of an instinctive
style theoretically could could put
ballistics in an arrow you can certainly
get arrows that have got sort of
gunpowder in and a charge that that sort
of causes a lot of damage it's really
hard to shoot in a helmet but he's got
like a very he's overdrawing the bow as
well he's pulling it back right right
back to here um which is which is a
technique that that that can be used I
was in a a little film once where I had
to try and shoot in a gas mask and you
can't get an anchor point in a in a gas
mask it's really difficult arrows do
bounce you can skip arrows off the
ground um I've seen people skip arrows
along water there's a trick I used to do
and there's like a little wooden ramp
and I could shoot the arrow at the
wooden ramp and it would skip up I'm
going
four
p
[Music]
what he's got there he he he's taken
what three four arrows he's going to
hold them in his hand uh as his shoot so
he's not using a quiver he's using his
own hand as the quiver and it's a it's a
technique where where you sort of draw
the arrow from your hand almost onto the
bow straight away as I mentioned before
the the kind of more Eastern style of
shooting uh very quick succession um
again getting as many arrows in the air
as as
possible
he's got this very low Anchor Point uh
very floating Anchor Point that's
difficult to get accuracy but he's using
an Eastern style bow and when you know
the sort of bow that You' use on a
horseback and you can't really get a
good solid Anchor Point when you're in a
horseback and some of those archers are
F phenomenally accurate so maybe Anchor
Point isn't everything for this sort of
particular style and I love Pedro Pascal
I love Matt Damon ah I'm going to give
it we're got
five he's got a a crossbow uh with a
scope on it now the thing is with a
crossbow they are very accurate um it
takes a lot of the human error out of
the of the bow so it's literally pulling
a trigger uh as long as it's cocked
correctly uh and you've got the bolt
in I did notice uh he shoots the he
shoots the bolt uh but the the bow Still
Remains cocked she's holding it for a
very long time that's a very long time
to hold a Trad bow Olympic archery is
slightly different you tend to have a
little um device on your bow that that
sort of clicks when the arrow gets to a
certain length and you you hold the full
draw for a bit and expand on the shot so
the shot sequence on a on an Olympic
style bow would be longer but she is at
full draw for a very long time the other
thing I noticed about her being at full
draw the way she's got the string it's
it's down the side of her nose um now
what's going to happen if that was a a
fully-fledged full poundage bow and she
had a decent release that's going to
whip right past her nose and cause a lot
of pain it's going to hurt and if you do
it again and again and again uh it it
it's it's
horrible
I imagine there is some sort of indexing
on the arrow for her to sort of feel on
Modern arrows you you tend to have like
a little plastic index uh notch on there
so you can feel which orientation the
arrow is so imagine it's similar sort of
situation let's give the Hunger Games a
six my favorite kind of archery movies I
mean two of them are in there the the
Robin Hood prince of Thieves which I
think is absolutely fantastic it's a
little bit cheesy the other one in there
is is Deliverance it's such a good
representation of archery it shows
archery as it's never perfect there's
there's always something that can go
wrong and if you like this video why not
aim at the one above my head and check
it
out